[Musique]
bref en position
et Mickey tu te rappelles ce que tu dis
c'est quand on est des petits tu m'as
fait promettre de jamais le redire
oublie ce que j'ai dit tu en as encore
un stock ça me démangeait depuis des
années
on a un D53
je suis là
[Musique]
tous les deux vous êtes tellement mignon
que je pourrais presque vous faire des
papouilles
les gars il arrive il arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
assez la leçon est terminée
on s'est fait péter le cul comme il faut
que 50 secondes avant que les toxines
soient lâchées
ça vous dit une partie de sots
certains l'appellent aussi le sautent
on va jouer à sauts
on va faire ce que dit Léo
enfin j'ai commencé
[Musique]
un jour comme les autres dans la vie
d'un homme d'action c'est que ah non non
je me lève plus tard
en ligne de commande jusque c'est plus
utilisé en codage depuis 15 ans c'est
vrai j'ai lu des trucs dessus mais c'est
pas pour les gars
on s'occupe de lui
experion des toxines dans 5
4 3 2
[Musique]
système désactiver
pour tout le monde
[Musique]
retenez-la
si la flèche s'effondre éclatoxine on
prend contact avec le sol tout sera
contaminés sur un rayon 20 km quels sont
nos chances d'empêcher de s'instruise
0,003800
mais Léo j'ai dit personne ne bouge je
vais lâcher
[Musique]
c'est tout ce qui reste ma petite
ceci m'appartient
[Musique]
il faut balancer vers lui
elle est trop forte
[Musique]